all right now we're always there we're
really at the tail end okay so part G
I'm just going to squeeze I reckon I can
do it paji it says what happens to Q the
amount of salt as T tends toward
infinity mmm
have a look here's our expression for Q
up here is Q so when T gets really huge
when T gets really huge what is
happening to this object over here just
look at that little e to the all of that
e ^ hmm that negative at the front means
I could rewrite it if I wanted to
that guy just over there I could rewrite
it as 1 on e to the W T on a thousand
sad okay that's what that negative sign
does to the index and then this thing
down here this thing is getting enormous
right because you're saying let T go to
infinity so this denominator is getting
huge the denominator is getting huge
which means the actual number is getting
tiny so this entire object here is just
disappearing does that make sense and on
our graph that makes sense doesn't it
right you see the graph actually helps
you picture what's happening so as T
approaches infinity Q approaches 2000
you can literally see it happen okay
final step now they actually asked us to
do something with this model okay it
says if there's a kilo of salt in the
tank after that amount of hours 5w what
do you W what I asked you is to actually
know it's the amount of I still have it
written on the board oh no it's the
amount of water flowing in they want us
to calculate a flow rate in an hour okay
so how do I use the piece of information
they've given me what do I where do I
put that
q is equal to a kilo of salt represents
what units am I talking about well I
think grams so Q is going to be a
thousand when x equal to five and three
quarters not five and three quarters
because that's in ours right so
everything I've been writing on the
board has been in minutes as one of the
handy things about writing minutes over
and over again you're like and who's got
time to write that it's a I do because I
don't want to forget what you can attend
dealing with right so it's worth the
time investment it's just a few seconds
how many minutes is it
it's 345 q is that when T is that where
are you gonna put that into which
equation you got a lot to choose from
where's it going to go yeah my orange
one right that's why I highlighted it
okay so you can see if I take these two
values and chuck them into there this
will become a constant that will become
a cluster what will be left behind
the only printing rule that's left is W
which is the one I want okay so can you
go ahead do your substitution do your
rearrangement you're gonna have to take
logs of both sides and so on because you
got double use up in the power I can
tell me give me I feel from this one
maybe three or four decimal places on
this and then we will approximate
accordingly
watch out for your negatives as things
fly around it's easy to
hmm
[Applause]
um this slide here I got suspicious
because I was like I did that number
didn't appear in my working I wonder
where it came from and then I realized
just be careful
arithmetic you've got number could I get
a show hands who has a number any number
okay great that's a good number of you
so I think you should get two point zero
zero nine and then some other stuff as
well yes so I'm going to approximate
that and say okay let's just go for two
to the that's one significant figure for
us that's a flow rate of two liters per
minute which is what's going on if you
have to think about oh ok so it takes
five and three call with six hours to
get to this point here to this half
concentration because we know where it's
going where there it is whether the end
state is it takes us that long because
yeah it's not flowing in particularly
fast given the entire volume of the of
the tank okay admittedly it's a bit hard
to do a sense check on this one because
I don't routinely work with 1000 liters
tanks of water and this kind of amount
of salt I have no concept of what those
numbers are in a practical sense but at
least the numbers seem reasonable it's
not like a negative or hundreds or
something like that okay so conclusion
this is a tough question if you've got a
question like this that would be hard
very hard work a lot of this this
thinking over here it's easy when you
see it laid out but thinking through how
you're going to combine the rates
together that takes some real thought
and attention and time I'm gonna
encourage you you see this graph here it
didn't take as long to do it but I think
it's really helpful it helps you see
what's going on in your mind and then
you can answer the rest of the questions
just carefully think about what criteria
you've been given and where is the
appropriate place to put them in